[Musik]
hi und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen Folge Skyblock mit Luca meine
Damen und Herren wir dürfen gar nicht
lange Zeit verlieren denn es steht mal
wieder unfassbar viel auf der
To-Do-Liste von daher starten wir direkt
mit einem Nachtrag der letzten Folge ich
brauche dafür allerdings erstmal meinen
lavaimer um hier eine neue Cobblestone
Bruchstein
generatorenmaschine mal eben fix
aufzubauen weil wir uns ein Schwert
craften müssen das habe ich ja am Ende
der letzten Folge gesagt ich habe
aktuell keins mehr und ich habe auch
keine Bruchsteine mehr glaube ich oder
habe ich mich jetzt verguckt hier oben
waren ja drin nee ich habe keine
Buchstaben mehr um mir gerade ein zu
craften deswegen müssen wir jetzt mal
fix eins machen ich ähm setze erstmal
hier vorne einen normalen Steine damit
wenn ich den abbauen
dass das nicht so schlimm ist wenn er
dann in die Lava fällt setzen hier ich
kann ihn nicht sagen das finde ich immer
noch Minecraft ne
dass das da jetzt einfach nicht
durchfließen kann dann schnappen wir uns
allerdings von hier vorne in Wassereimer
bauen hier vorne das ab den Wasser
einmal hier rein und wenn wir jetzt das
hier vorne abbauen seht ihr schon haben
wir ein Cobblestone Generator der gerade
zwar mitten in unserer Insel hier ist
allerdings sieht es ja bereits im Titel
eingeblendet heute ist die Insel
Reparatur Folge und da freue ich mich
wirklich extrem krass drauf zwei Steine
reichen sogar direkt schon fünf
nehmen jetzt hier unser Holz raus und
laufen mal ganz fix oben zum crafting
table ich freue mich extrem auf die
heutige Episode weil ich mich
tatsächlich bisher oft keine einzige
Folge Skyblock mit Luca so brutal
vorbereitet habe wie auf die heutige und
ich blende euch auch erstmal ganz fixe
timelaps ein wie hier kommen weil davon
brauchen wir heute wirklich eine Menge
denn ich will
[Musik]
so meine Damen und Herren ich werde
jetzt gerade fast zehn Minuten lang
Bruchstein abgebaut ich habe hier
eineinhalb Stacks noch und oben
rutschelt auch noch was hier in den
Öfen und ihr seht auch schon dass ich
eine Menge Steinziegel mir hier gemacht
habe das sieht ganz einfach daran weil
es ja heute die Insel Reparatur Folge
ist und ich tatsächlich diese blöden
Mauern hier endlich mal weg bauen möchte
das war ja mehr provisorisch ich finde
Bruchstein wirklich nicht schön in
Minecraft und habe mir überlegt dass
alles hier zumindest den Rand unserer
Insel jetzt nicht alles hier unten
drunter was wäre sicherheitshalber
unterhöhlt haben hier überall mit diesem
Stein mit diesem Bruchstein das möchte
ich nicht abbauen oder sieht man ja eh
nicht was ich allerdings abbauen möchte
ist das hier weil das sieht man immer
von außen und dann möchte ich da drauf
tatsächlich auch Zäune stellen und das
schlagen wir tatsächlich zwei Fliegen
mit einer Klappe denn äh 20 Zäune zu
craften ist tatsächlich auch und das ist
auch ein kleiner Nachmittag zu letzten
Folge weil ich das in der letzten Folge
noch nicht so richtig auf dem Schirm
hatte das ist tatsächlich auch eine
Challenge 20 Zäune ist eine Challenge
und 20 Zaun Tore von daher werde ich mir
gleich auch noch neue Zäune machen und
diese selbstverständlich aus welchem
Holz
ist ein Hinweis aus welchem Holz das
gemacht wird jedoch bauen wir hier vorne
jetzt erstmal noch die Mauer zu Ende ab
und schauen dann jetzt auch mal hier
dass wir das hier abbauen und dadurch
bekommen wir auch noch mal Bruchsteine
die wir auch on Mast benötigen denn wir
verkraften die weiter zu Bruchstein
Stufen um heute in der Folge auch noch
rüber zu gehen zu dieser Insel
wir brauchen die Erde da unten
wiederum für eine andere Sache die ich
auch noch für heute vor habe von daher
eine ganz fixe timelapse noch mal weil
ich muss noch mal abbauen und jetzt wird
es eh Nacht
[Musik]
so meine Damen und Herren die Folge ist
für euch wahrscheinlich gerade mal vier
Minuten alt bei mir bin ich hier bei
einer halben Stunde ihr seht schon ich
habe ein zwei drei vier fünfeinhalb
sechs Bruchsteine abgebaut und natürlich
auch noch das was ich vorhin hier die
ganze Zeit gebuddelt hat also locker 7
Stacks äh die Sonne bzw der Mond neigt
sich auch schon wieder ein bisschen die
Nacht neigt sich auch schon wieder dem
Ende zu da hinten sind einige Monster
gespannt da wurde mir diesen Weg
unter dem Ding hier vorne sehe ich doch
einen eingeblendet hier so ein Creeper
darum soll es allerdings nicht gehen
also soll es eigentlich doch denn mir
wurde auch was unten in die Kommentare
geschrieben und zwar das hier äh Luca
die Monster die droppen nur Sachen wenn
du während die sterben in der Nähe von
denen bist das heißt wir müssen jetzt
ein bisschen warten noch so eine halbe
Minute oder so dann ist er wieder Tag
dann gehen wir da hinten mal in die Ecke
und schauen mal äh wo äh die vielleicht
etwas stoppen könnten und ob wir
vielleicht äh Eisen bekommen das auch in
die Kommentare geschrieben dass das mit
einer geringen Wahrscheinlichkeit auch
gedroppt wird von Monstern wenn ich
sterben und äh noch viel wichtiger
gerade für uns eigentlich erstmal
Knochenmehl da wurde mir allerdings auch
das hier unten in die Kommentare
geschrieben bzw das ist der gleiche
kommentar von gerade da hat mir nämlich
die Person geschrieben dass wir
Knochenmehl auch über einen Komposter
bekommen können ich glaube da vorne ich
mache jetzt erstmal hier und zwar
weil das hat mir auch schon in ich bin
gerade ein bisschen durch den Wind äh
liegt aber daran weil ich so viele
Punkte habe die ich heute abarbeiten
möchte und ich will nicht dass die Folge
schon wieder eine halbe Stunde lang wird
wie die letzte Folge also ähm Holzstufen
zu einem U angeordnet bringt uns einen
Komposter und ein Komposter den können
wir jetzt hier vorne hinstellen da
können wir wieder ein bisschen tricksen
nämlich eine Erde mehr uns gönnen indem
wir dort auch einen was hatten wir
überall ich glaube Fichtenholz Bretter
ne können wir fichtenholzbretter auch
untersetzen und äh hauen jetzt einfach
mal einen nee warte sind nicht nur das
Wetter
guck mal es ist Eiche
also wenn wir hier Pfusch am Bau machen
dann aber auch richtig dann kommen die
fichtenholzbretter Weg wir nehmen uns
einen eichenholzbrett und packen das
hier hin
so wir haben Komposter meine Damen und
Herren und können jetzt so Sachen wie
beispielsweise wir haben ja eh nur
dieses kleine Feld weil wir wir sprinten
fast nie deswegen brauchen wir jetzt
nicht so viel essen weil wir werden gar
nicht solche Entfernungen zurücklegen
wie bei Minecraft mit Luca Staffel 1
jetzt können wir unsere Samen nehmen
können alles in den Komposter reinhauen
und ähm haben jetzt
zack ein Knochenmehl bringt uns zwar
nicht viel ich werde das auch erstmal
hier reinpacken allerdings nee hier in
die naturkiste allerdings haben wir auch
so Sachen wie Eichen Setzlinge
reinpacken oder Weizen können oder
irgendwann haben wir ganz viele Kakteen
die muss ich auch noch mal anpflanzen wo
habe ich denn hier die ganzen den ganzen
Sand
[Musik]
mein Sand ist weg
ist der hier runtergefallen als wir
gestorben sind
gibt es auf irgendein guck mal jetzt
habe ich das mit den Monstern auch
verpasst oder
ist sie noch irgendein Monster ich
glaube nicht nee
kein Sand
kein Sand kein Sand da hinten erst recht
nicht da vorne weiß ich nicht warum sich
das abbaut weil da ist kein Holz mehr
zwischen da haben wir auch keinen Sand
die insolventen aber schon abgebaut und
da haben wir nur Pilze
ist aber nicht schlimm meine Damen und
Herren dann können wir leider aber die
Challenge mit dem grünen Farbstoff nicht
machen weil wir dafür Kakteen
[Musik]
igt ich bin so ein Trottel
ich habe meinen komplettes ich habe ich
bin so ich habe ja mein kompletten Sand
zur Glas gemacht
[Musik]
ich bin ja der oberste der größte
22 Glas kann ich dann Kaktus drauf an
Pflanzen ich glaube nicht gut die
Challenge ist dreimal Kaktus grüne Farbe
ich weiß nicht kann ich das jetzt so
einfach machen nee wie geht denn das wie
kann man denn aus Kakteen Farbe machen
muss man die nicht einfach da reinpacken
oder muss man das muss man das in einer
Workbench machen nee geht auch nicht ein
paar Sekunden
keine Panik auf der Titanic Leute
wir müssen uns nur verbrennen
[Musik]
ich habe absolut keinen Plan was ich mit
dreimal grünen Farbstoff jetzt anstellen
soll aber es war eine Challenge und
genauso war es eine Challenge
Fichtenholz Zaun Stöcker und Fichten
Stämme bzw sie haben auch noch weiter
genauso war es eine Challenge habe ich
ja vorhin schon gesagt 20
Zoll zu machen egal aus welchem Material
ich weiß nicht ob Zäune so gehen warte
mal zack ja doch drei raus das heißt ich
brauche noch ein bisschen Fichtenholz
Bretter ich mache mir mal direkt ein
ganzes Deck wir haben hier genug Stämme
hier überall zum Verarbeiten zack zack
zack zack wir brauchen insgesamt 20
Stück dann haben wir auch hier
die nächste Challenge am Start ich mache
mir mal ein paar mehr weil wir die ja
hier vorne hinsetzen werden als
Sicherung so dass wir nicht runterfallen
zack hier vorne alles voll easy schon
viel schöner aus wenn man so guckt sieht
schon viel schöner aus und dann machen
wir das ganze hier vorne auch noch mal
eben schnell zack zack zack zack zack
zack zack
können wir auch ein bisschen weitergehen
fällt mir gerade auf machen wir mal drei
weiter bis zu dem Baum hier vorne und äh
wir müssen ja dann eh den Weg weiter
bauen zu der Insel dahinten irgendwann
das machen wir allerdings nicht heute
heute wollen wir rüber gehen zu der
Insel nach vorne bevor wir das
allerdings machen werde ich mir erstmal
kurz einen Wassereimer nehmen weil ich
habe das natürlich schon wieder alles in
meiner testwelt hier vorgebaut wir äh
möchten hier vorne unseren
Generator hinsetzen ich habe keine
Spitzhacke mehr die brauche ich auf
jeden Fall da kann ich mir eben fix eine
neue machen nee nach oben ich muss noch
ein bisschen mich hier dran gewöhnen
dass jetzt alles hier mittlerweile lang
und Ordnung hat zack ich habe auch keine
Stecker mehr perfekt machen wir uns
nochmal zwei Stecker zack zack haben
meine neue haben wir nicht haben wir so
haben wir eine neue Spitzhacke und
werden jetzt hier vorne unseren
Generator hinbauen den bauen wir einfach
mal aus Steinziegel habe ich mir
vorgenommen weil das deutlich schöner
aussieht wir brauchen sechs Blöcke Platz
vier fünf sechs von daher werde ich auch
hier vorne die Erde bitte nicht ja gut
nicht runtergefallen äh werde ich auch
hier vorne mal eben fix den Baum abbauen
ich finde es sieht sehr schön aus und
das hat so einen kleinen Allee Charakter
zu unserer Monster fahren ich weiß nicht
ob man das unbedingt haben will aber ich
finde wenn man so von hier vorne schaut
und man sieht so diese Bäume ist schon
ganz cool aus aber wir haben wirklich
genug fichtenholzbäume und daher ja
können wir auch theoretisch hier erstmal
nichts stehen haben aber gut bauen wir
das hier vorne mal ab habe ich Stufen
noch genug ja 18 habe ich also 1 2 3 4 5
6 haben wir am Start war noch das hier
vorne ab und hier und ersetzen dann
jetzt hier alles durch Steinziegel
Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam
[Musik]
ja
wir müssen das ganz schnell nach da
vorne setzen hier ist auch ein Zaun
einfach flöten gegangen fällt mir gerade
auf den kann ich noch mal eben fix neu
machen wir haben noch genügend Sachen
das heißt ich muss wieder nach oben
gehen immer ein shot wenn ich mich
vertue das hier unten eigentlich das
Ding ist so zack den nehmen wir und
setzen den Zaun hier vorne wieder hin
das ist nämlich genau der Grund warum
ich das ganze hier vorne hin verfrachten
möchte und dann nehmen wir auch schon
direkt wieder unsere Steinziegel und
bauen hier beim Bam Bam Bam habe ich
genügend nee habe ich nicht aber ich
kann mir direkt noch mal eben ein paar
neue machen so sollte jetzt hoffentlich
ausreichen denn ähm wir schauen jetzt
mal eins zwei drei so so so so so so so
so so hier vorne kommt das Wasser rein
weil ich die Lava hier hin platzieren
möchte damit die nicht so nah an unserer
Insel drin schon gesehen der ist zwei
drei Blöcke entfernt aber das Feuer geht
trotzdem rüber ähm deswegen kommt hier
die Lava rein Zack und das Wasser fließt
dann hier runter wenn wir diesen Block
hier allerdings schon geht's hier nach
unten deswegen muss ich jetzt eben
schnell mal Wasser nehmen an der Seite
runter und das ganze
jetzt auf Harakiri angelehnt wieder oh
das habe ich da jetzt gemacht ach so das
ist dieser Minecraft Fehler ne da muss
man ganz gut so machen zack so jetzt
geht's
muss ich mal eben gucken wie ich das
hier hinkriege was das Loch da zack
zwei haben wir drunter gesetzt da muss
man nämlich zwei drunter setzen das ist
ein ganz dummer Minecraft Fehler weil
das Wasser sonst nicht richtig abfließt
bei diesen halbblöcken und wir nehmen ja
diese halbblöcke um einfach weil
da geht's doch
man sieht dich nicht mal
boah ey einmal mit Profis ist mir
reichen nee reicht das jetzt nicht ich
will noch einmal ganz kurz dass sie eben
schön machen so von daher gehe ich jetzt
aber eben kurz noch mal ach komm egal in
Minecraft Villa kannst du jetzt wirklich
am Arsch vorbei gehen ich gehe mal
einmal kurz noch mal hier runter um
diesen Block hier abzubauen das dauert
jetzt ein bisschen aber der stört mich
ich hoffe ich kriege das hin in der Zeit
dass ich jetzt nicht sterbe guck mal
meine Blubberblasen ey das ist richtig
wahr oder also sollte man eigentlich
schaffen
komm schon
sehr gut zack haben wir hingekriegt so
Wasser einmal wieder aufnehmen das da
vorne fließt ab hier können wir wieder
den Stein hinsetzen Bam Bam und
dementsprechend haben wir jetzt hier ein
Loch und können hier das Wasser
reinsetzen erstmal noch hier ein hier
das Wasser das fließt jetzt hier runter
wenn wir hier jetzt einmal so machen
können wir hier dann den Stein abbauen
und jetzt nehmen wir uns von hier vorne
unsere Lava zack
BAM und haben hoffentlich
einen Generator
es war wundervoll
du kannst dann hier so hinstellen
und mit einem grandiosen Ausblick
abbauen und es sieht doch gar nicht mal
so schlecht aus weil es ist aus diesem
steinziegeln das sind weit und breit
nichts was anfangen könnte zu brennen
und ist hier vorne
können wir jetzt endlich mal alles
abbauen
Erde hierhin und es sieht wieder schön
aus meine Damen und Herren es wird
wieder nachts von daher blende ich euch
jetzt den ganz kurze timelaps ein wie
ich mich dort vorne hin bewege
muss ich hier vorne wieder was abbauen
oder wir machen es aber hier das können
wir auch wir machen es hier euch auf
jeden Fall erstmal eine timelapse
[Musik]
und Leute trymacs hier ja
da seht ihr schon das Problem
an der Insel
[Musik]
da wartet ein Creeper
und ich bin ganz ehrlich wir können uns
aktuell nicht erlauben dass er da
irgendwas in die Luft springen denn wir
brauchen ganz ganz viel Gras für eine
Sache die mir ebenfalls in die
Kommentare geschrieben wurde und zwar
das hier
man kann wohl eine Plattform machen
[Musik]
die
25 Blöcke entfernt ist von meiner Insel
also dann irgendwie dort hinten und wenn
man die gut ausleuchtet und wenn man da
Gras hinbaut also eine grasbrücke von
quasi hier rechts darüber hierhin 25
Blöcke entfernt dann spawnen dort
eventuell mit einer geringen
Wahrscheinlichkeit Tiere Schafe Hühner
Schweine Kühe ein Special chillig für
ein Bett klar wir können auch da hinten
hin und uns einfach voll abbauen schon
gemerkt aber ich finde es auch ein
bisschen mit Tieren zu interagieren so
wie Minecraft mit Luca Staffel 1 von
daher starten jetzt eine kleine Aktion
und werden diesen Creeper einen Weg
bauen so dass er kommt irgendwie nicht
oder können wir
ganz frech
okay
und ich habe den Wassereimer vergessen
so meine Damen und Herren ihr seht es
bereits unten im Inventar eingeblendet
ich habe den Wassereimer geholt ich habe
auch noch ein paar mehr bruchsteinstufen
geholt ich habe noch eine steinax
gemacht und ich habe beide Brote von mir
gegessen weil ich hier rüber gesprintet
bin und dann dachte ich komme dann kann
ich auch eben kurz vernampen ähm so wir
werden wieder harakira zu machen was
einmal hier runter und alles
unter Höhlen mit Bruchsteinen zack zack
zack zack zack zack zack zack zack zack
zack zack und dann noch kann ich an der
Seite immer noch mal checken ja gar
nicht so dann hier auch noch mal beim
BAM
dann können wir uns nämlich auf den hier
schon mal hinbewegen können uns das
Wasser ah das ist erstmal da weil es
jetzt doch irgendwie runterfallen sollte
okay die Erde habe ich da gerade eine
Herde Weg ey das ist wirklich no joke
mal in einem Projekt Erde gefühlt
hinterherhechten werde hätte ich niemals
gedacht aber bei Skyblock ist das halt
leider so zack hier vorne müsste ich
noch unter Höhen nee ist schon so wir
bauen uns wieder von unten nach oben
hoch und machen als letztes das mit dem
Baum weil das Holz wirklich das aller
unwichtigste ist die Erde ist einfach
das Wichtigste in Skyblock weil man das
einfach nicht bekommt so so so
und ihr zwei da vorne auch noch beim BAM
bzw ja ist ja noch eine Ebene mehr so
noch und du hier vorne alles abbauen
so zack
weck mich vor allem ne
irgendwas Wasser mal weg oh nein jetzt
geht die Sonne schon wieder auf und die
ganzen ah das sind auch keine das klappt
nicht mit diesem kramster ey
[Musik]
so meine Damen und Herren ich habe hier
vorne jetzt mal den kompletten
tropenbaum abgebaut einsetzen habe
mitgenommen wir brauchen es eh nicht ich
weiß dass man bei tropenbäumen auch vier
Sätze nebeneinander setzen kann dann
kriegt man so einen fettenbaum aber ich
finde es immer ja eigentlich eher
stressig als dass das irgendwie sinnvoll
wäre weil schau dich mal an wie hoch das
Ding war ich finde die Blätter nicht
schön mit diesem knalligen grün da finde
ich Fichtenbäume wirklich schöner ähm
und wir haben auch gar keine Quests mit
diesem Tropenholz oder was das ist wie
heißt das überhaupt das heißt doch
truppenbaumstämme damit haben wir gar
nichts zu tun warum kommt davon raus
oh das kann sein wegen unserer Farm
da müssen wir da auch noch mal nach
unten ich werde jetzt einfach mal hier
vorne so ein kleines Loch bauen hier
einen Wassereimer rein und dann das Loch
einfach von hier ganz entspannt zu bauen
zack zack wieder zwei Blöcke damit wir
nicht den Fehler haben und jetzt wieder
Luft holen und das Ding hier abbauen
ich sage euch das ist halt so stressig
ne
drei Herzen
und wir haben nicht mal richtig was zu
essen um das aufzufüllen gerade
allerdings setzen wir hier vorne dann
auch wieder den Stein hin den halben den
unteren haben wir gerade abgebaut nehmen
uns hier das Wasser einen unteren zur
Sicherheit die Erde in Fichtenholz
Zaunbau auf und wenn wir jetzt mal nicht
sprinten besser so viel leben wir jetzt
auch nicht wenn wir jetzt mal hier rüber
laufen und uns jetzt jeden Moment
einfach mal ganz entspannt
Insel
hier vorne haben wir jetzt einen kleinen
Knöppel unter mir auch noch einer aber
es ist zumindest trocken die Insel
Reparatur nimmt Fahrt auf meine Damen
und Herren ich bin bei mehr als einer
Stunde in der ruheaufnahme und er hat
auch tatsächlich eine kleine Frage an
euch
ihr kennt von Minecraft mit Luca Staffel
1 ich habe kein einziges Mal gecheatet
in 100 Folgen ich will es auch hier
eigentlich nicht machen aber ich merke
wie viel Zeit es zieht diese ganzen
Brücken hier abzubauen bauen werde ich
die aber beim Abbauen habe ich überlegt
in den Creative Mode zu wechseln um
diese ganze Plörre einfach mal weg zu
machen also klar wir müssen erstmal noch
da unten ne das machen wir auch
irgendwann in den nächsten Folgen aber
schreibt immer gerne unten in die
Kommentare ob ihr was dagegen hätte wenn
ich in den Creative Mode gehe und dass
er alles weg mache das geht locker 100
mal so schnell und es ist eher sogar
einen cheaten in die entgegengesetzte
Richtung weil ich beim Abbauen noch ab
und zu so einen bruchsteinstufe bekomme
fürs Inventar und beim Cheaten bekomme
ich gar nichts mir geht's einfach nur
darum ein bisschen Zeit zu sparen weil
mit einer Stunde nur durch das Bauen und
wenn ich das jetzt alles noch abbauen
würde das wird jetzt wieder 10 Minuten
dauern von da vorne bis hier rüber zu
laufen also schreibt mir das mal bitte
gern unten in die Kommentare und ich
hatte für heute tatsächlich noch
deutlich viel mehr geplant wie
beispielsweise das hier richtig zu einem
schönen See zu machen um das hier vorne
das können wir auch eben machen
soll der Geiz komm ich bin eh schon bei
über einer Stunde dann können wir auch
noch wieder mal komplett überziehen also
hier vorne habe ich jetzt alles abgebaut
ich werde auch jetzt allerdings nur
diese Seite hier wieder neu zu gleistern
mit den bruchsteinstufen weil ich eben
genau in diesem Bereich hier so einen
kleinen See bauen möchte und den möchte
ich auch nur bauen weil es äh
tatsächlich auch ein Teil einer
Challenge ist und ich habe keinen
richtigen Platz sonst für einen
vernünftigen sehe hier vorne hört man
vielleicht machen aber ich finde sie
eigentlich ganz schön weil in die
Richtung müssen immer noch einmal gehen
und dann können wir das alles abgebaut
werden dann haben wir die Seite
eigentlich komplett durch also der See
soll stattfinden was machen wir denn
machen wir mal so zack zack zack zack
zack zack zack zack zack zack zack zack
zack zack vielleicht so in den Dreh und
dann waren wir auch hier vorne noch mal
eben wieder ab wann
hier vorne geht er dann so ein bisschen
um die Kurve ihr merkt auch schon ich
habe mir gerade Fichtenholz Fichtenholz
Brett Stufen für das unten liegende Ding
weil ich in meiner Testfeld das ganze
getestet habe
[Musik]
ist mit dem See abgeschlossen sieht
jetzt nicht allzu schön aus ich weiß
aber gibt dem ganzen mal Zeit bis hier
das war grün rüber gewachsen ist
ach am liebsten hätte ich noch so viel
mehr Erde um das hier alles grün zu
machen aber es ist schwierig
es ist leider einfach nur schwierig oh
nein das jetzt unten durch weil das in
der half slaps oh
du kannst es dir doch wirklich nicht
ausdenken
das
Leute ich sag euch das ist ein Zeichen
um die Folge zu beenden wir haben eine
Menge geschafft hier vorne ist auch noch
einer so wir haben wirklich eine Menge
geschafft wir haben die Insel Reparatur
vorangetrieben das war zwar keine
richtige Challenge aber dennoch war es
wichtig zu tun so hier vorne jetzt ein
hin wir haben das mit dem See geschafft
wir haben das mit den Zäunen geschafft
es gibt auch noch die Challenge Zaun
Tore es gibt auch noch die
fackel-challenge die wollte ich heute
machen wir haben allerdings trotzdem
ganz ganz viele Sachen geschafft unter
anderem das mit dem warte mal ich mache
Kiri abbauen und hoch wir haben das mit
dem und diese diese kann generell jetzt
komplett wegfällen jetzt unendliche
Wasserquelle deswegen nehme ich mir mal
eben schnell hier die Erde noch mal eben
fix raus und bau das hier jetzt zu dann
laufen wir auch nicht immer so dumm
durch ich muss ja auch mal ein bisschen
mehr ausrichten ne mach mal hier meine
Fackeln einer habe ich noch mache ich
immer noch nee du sollst hier drauf
und die verfrachte ich mal nach hier ich
habe Schiss dass sie ein bisschen was
bauen also ein bisschen Fackeln muss ich
mir tatsächlich noch mal eben machen wo
haben wir denn die stärker hier hey ich
bin schon wieder so einer Überlänge ich
werde so lange im Schnitt sitzen ich
habe da gerade gar keine Zeit für nein
wir haben auch keine Kohle mehr ich habe
dir aufgebraucht für die beiden Dings da
muss ich jetzt wieder das meine noch mal
eben schnell ich habe jetzt keinen Bock
oder willst du was soll ich ihm kurz ich
nehme kurz die Fackel hier erinnert mich
mal bitte in den Kommentaren dran dass
ich die Fackel da das nächste Mal wieder
hinsetze ich habe ein bisschen Schiss
dass es hier zu ohne euch ausgeleuchtet
ist dass da was von hier kann nichts
drauf spawnen sind die Harz und hier
vorne sollte alles relativ clean sein
ich beende die Folge ich bin bei ach
dicker ich bin bei anderthalb Stunden
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen lasst
einen Daumen hoch da wenn es das getan
hat abonniert den Kanal wenn ihr weiter
Videos nichts verpassen wollt und klickt
auf die Glocke bekommt den
Benachrichtigung wenn ein neues Video
online geht neue Folge Skyblock in drei
bis vier Tagen denke ich ähm
aber wir müssen in der nächsten Folge
richtig viele Challenge schaffen die
wollte ich eigentlich heute noch packen
aber das klappt jetzt nicht mehr
zeitlich haut rein Leute ich habe euch
lieb ciao
[Musik]